In this video, I will teach you from
scratch what is order flow and how you
can use it in your trading. Order flow,
unlike price action, uses a deeper level
of information. It uses charts that show
you the real interaction between buyers
and sellers and the battle between big
traders and institutions that happens in
the market every single day. This is a
trading style that is widely known and
used [music] in the institutional
trading space and that I used to trade
live in front of millions of people all
over the internet and to trade
profitably my personal account over the
last decade. In this complete guide, we
will start from what order flow actually
is, how order flow creates price
movements, and how you can read order
flow in real time to find the best
trading setups. And I will show you my
favorite order flow tool that allows me
to filter out only the big traders to
truly follow the footprint of the smart
money in the market. Let's get started.
By the way, I will share with you this
entire map on my Telegram channel. Let's
start by understanding what the market
is. So, the market is made by the
interaction of two forces, the intent to
buy and the intent to sell, rooted
through a central exchange for regulated
markets and represented
as volume. Now, let's see how this
interaction unfold. We have two type of
forces in the markets, the aggressive
participants and the passive
participants. And in this example, you
can see on the right side the order book
and on the left side the market orders.
Now, let's assume that
a market order by 25 contracts it's
about to hit the book. And these
aggressive buyers are accepting the
prices by the best ask, the so-called
passive sellers, the passive forces that
we saw before, that are providing 33
units at a price level of 101. Now, the
33 unit of passive sell orders are
sufficient to satisfy the 25 buy market
orders that are the aggressive forces.
And after execution, only eight sell
orders remain in the best ask, and the
price moves up to 101. Price is now
here. Here, we can see a new candle with
the order flow tool that represented the
executed order called the footprint and
a record, a detailed record of what
occurred on both the bid on the left
side and the ask on the right. And it
provide a list of all the aggressive
sellers who entered the market, and on
the right of all the aggressive buyers
that joined the action. Now, the 41
passive buy orders are sufficient to
satisfy the interaction of the 25
sell market orders. And after the
execution, there are 16 contract year
buy orders that remain in best bid, and
the price moves down to 99. The
footprint, now, have recorded both the
25 execution that we saw before and the
sell order that we see executed on the
horizontal level 99. Now, in the
previous case, we have seen how the
price move and interact when the best
bid and ask are able to satisfy the
market order that are coming. Now, we
need to see what happens when the best
bid and ask are insufficient to fulfill
the demand. So, when we see 75
aggressive participants market order
that enters here, what happens to the
market? And in this case, the 75 buy
market order found only eight contract
on the 101 level, so the best ask. And
they moved directly to 102
to fill the remaining 67
contract. And you have a reflection on
this on the footprint that shows you the
executed order of
25 on the 99 and 32 on the 101. So we
move to the 102 level with 67 contract
of aggressive market participants. The
102 level don't have enough sell limit
order to be able to satisfy the buy
market demand. So, considering the order
matching, execution moved to the next
level available, that is 103. So we have
in the end on the footprint, we have 32
execution on the 101 level and 42
contract executed on 102 level and we
are moving
to the next level, that is 103. In this
case, the 75 aggressive orders that we
saw in the beginning received and
experienced a slippage of three tick
going to be filled completely at the 103
level with 31 remaining contract
available. So to summarize, we have two
forces that have different features. We
start with the passive forces, the limit
order that have pricing authority and
price certainty because they choose the
level where they want to be filled, but
they experience the execution
uncertainty. So they don't have the
guarantee to be filled because to be
filled, someone else need to accept this
level. The market orders have execution
authority and execution certainty
Because when you press buy market, it's
a guarantee that you will be executed,
but you don't know where. You don't have
price certainty because you can be
filled, for example, you can press buy
market on the 101 and be filled at 102
because maybe your order experience
execution. That's the reason they have
different features. The market orders
have price uncertainty and the limit
order have execution uncertainty. So now
we are on the Order Flow platform, deep
charts, and we will watch some live
interaction between execution, so
aggressive orders and passive liquidity.
As you can see, now we have 13 executed
sell market order at this horizontal
level, 6,841,
and now the price is rejecting. You can
see that the level of the price is
getting lower. This means that
aggressive sellers are executing order
at 6,841,
and they are meeting the liquidity on
the downside, and they are pushing the
passive liquidity down. They are eating
levels on the book on the downside, and
this is the reason you are watching this
interaction and price going down.
Because as we saw before in the example,
and you can see this also from the
closure of the candle in the footprint,
the candle it's in the majority
controlled by aggressive sell orders,
and is showing you also the level where
this sell aggressive market order are
concentrated. That is the horizontal
level where you see the yellow box and
the 53
aggressive order executed. And on the
book, we can see on the left side that
the liquidity is more thick on the
upside. as you can see there are 28 33
here and only 10. And this is the reason
we saw exactly in real time the sweeping
of the book. So, the aggressive orders
entering on the sell side and eating
three different level on the book. So,
the the aggressive orders, the sell
aggressive order are pushing and eating
levels of the book. Now you are seeing
an interaction where we have a maximum
level of aggression that is the 6 6,840
where the buyers are in complete control
and now the auction is changing. Now the
aggressive market order are pushing the
passive liquidity up. As you can see.
Sellers again protecting and we are
watching the live interaction of the
market. So, every time we go to this
level, the 6,841.5,
you can see that the aggressive sell
order enter back and push the liquidity
level down. Now we are back to 6,840.5,
so you can expect that now the buyers
protect this level and these aggressive
sellers get absorbed completely on this
level. Let's see how it goes. As you can
see, we have only five and 16 here and
we have 23 25 18 14. So, the path of
least resistance is on the upside. This
is what I call the path of least
resistance. And this is exactly what
happened. As you can see, the price
reached this level, rejected, and now
it's going back to the fair value of
this range. Now we are watching this
interaction in the London session, so
there is not a huge amount of volatility
and
interaction between participants, but as
you can see, we saw the horizontal level
of control of the sellers that is the
6,841.5,
and the horizontal point of control of
the buyers, that is the 6,840.
And this is the range where they
interact, and this is the range where
you see that the interaction between
aggressive and passive orders shift. So,
from the example that we saw before, we
understood the two forces, and we
understood their role. The role of
aggressive market forces is creating
pressure, okay? Moving the market. And
the role of passive orders is creating
resistance. And you can see this by
observing the book. Let's make this
example, okay? We have 122 total
contract on this
block here [snorts] on the book, and we
have a total of 273
on this part, okay? Which part do you
think will be more difficult to pierce
from the side of aggressive market
participants? Of course, this one is the
easier side to pierce. This one is the
more difficult. Why? Because this one
hold more resistance from passive market
participants. So, you need a lot more
aggression to pierce through this. Let's
go on, and let's understand in this
example that from the concept of path of
least resistance, it's easier for the
market to continue higher here and
pierce through these passive orders
instead of breaching through this level.
The concept of probability and the
concept of what's easier doesn't mean
that it's always like this, but it's an
information that we can use. In this
example that we have here, we have a
breakdown of forces. We have buyers on
the right side and the sellers on the
left side. And here we can see a huge
effort on the top from the buyers to
break this level that got completely
absorbed by passive forces. The sellers
on the other side received a lot of
result more because they did less effort
to achieve more results. The candle
closed sell here. So we have a short
candle with left less effort from the
sellers and a lot of effort from the
buyers that received zero reward. This
is the perfect case of absorption. Why?
Because you have no reward for buyers
and you have a lot of buy pressure.
Probably this candle will have positive
delta but negative closure. This is the
textbook example for absorption. Let's
see now an an example of aggression. So
I have word and high results. You have
the same breakdowns on the right of the
candle you can see the aggressive market
participants
on the buy side and you can see that
this strong move on the upside had a lot
of effort backing it and they got also
rewarded. Probably here we see a lot of
levels from the book that got swept and
we managed to close with a full green
candle. It means that in this case the
big buy effort got rewarded and you have
what we call an initiative auction and a
confirmation of the aggression of the
buyers. So in this case you can probably
guess that in the balance of forces
buyers won the battle and it's more it's
higher probability to see a continuation
on the next candles. Now let's go
through an example of book sweeping. So,
low effort and high result. In this
case, we see a lot of executed orders on
the bottom side of the candle, and then
we see a candle that closed with an
amazing reward. So, there is movement of
the candle, but there is an absence of
participants. So, we can see that there
are no sell limit players in all this
area. There are, but they are few, and
price moves, but not the money. So, in
this case, we show an example where the
effort is low and the result is high
because in this case, in this area that
I'm lining up for you, there were no
sell limit player. So, a small
aggression from the buyers swept
multiple levels of the book. Now, let's
introduce a new concept that is called
delta. Delta is the difference between
aggressive market participants on the
buy side and aggressive market
participants on the sell side. So, it's
the different on the horizontal level
from aggressive sell and aggressive buy
market participants. And we can have two
different representation of this
information. We can have an horizontal
visualization, and we can have a
vertical reference for the delta. On the
left side, what we are seeing here, it's
a delta footprint profile, and we can
see, for example, that the delta it's
really high from the point of view of
the sellers on the downside, but the
candle closed by. This is the perfect
absorption example that you can see from
delta footprint profile. On the right
side, if you want to use the vertical
delta information, we have
a market that is in a consolidation
phase here, and we can spot that all
these aggressive market participants
here got absorbed and the candle closed
green. This is a potential continuation
of the move and an absorption pattern
that you can spot using the delta per
candle in a vertical pack of data that
it's available on deep charts. And this
one needs to be set because usually you
will find the footprint on the left side
that is showing you the bid and ask. You
can set by choosing the difference
between them and it's called
specifically delta footprint. Now, let's
see an example of initiative auction.
So, a concept that is usually
representing follow-up and reward. In
this case, we can see from the executed
order a constant aggression of the
buyers. So, there is consistent pressure
on the upside. One side print that is
also called imbalance and you can use as
a really strong point to join the trend
when it's developing and you have a
strong delta. So, you have coherence of
information. A strong delta and a candle
that close on the upside. And in this
case, you can see that is the delta that
is leading the price on the upside. This
is the best example that you can have of
aggressive momentum and it's represented
by what we call initiative auction that
can also be spotted when you have an
outline from the vertical volume with a
reward from the close of the candle. So,
the market is telling you the price is
closing on the upside. So, you have an
actual result and the volume is
supporting this movement closing above
the average. This is aggressive market
participants putting the feet on the gas
and joining the trend on the upside and
it's usually an amazing signal if you
are a trend following trader. Now, let's
go through an example of absorption and
we can see here that we have an
absorption in the middle of the candle.
Okay? And we have value. So, an
efficiency and the price is the white
line that we can see here and we have a
sudden drop in the delta when this big
aggression arrive from the market orders
or the aggressive participant on the
sell side and it got completely
absorbed, got run through and
this market order got completely
absorbed on this horizontal level and
the price continued to push it down and
close the candle long. So you have the
price going up like ignoring this small
inefficiency in delta and the delta
followed through the price and the
candle closed long. This example here is
the reason I always watch the matching
of value and the matching of volume
here. So what the volume is doing, what
the aggressive market participants are
doing and what is the result, so the
correlation between the effort and the
results of the player. If we go on the
right, this one can be seen as a general
absorption because from the horizontal
volume you can see a lot of effort here,
but the candle closed green. So what is
telling us that all this input of volume
delta got absorbed and probably this
absorption happened here and we will
continue on the upside. The next example
that we can have is an exhaustion. In
this case we can see that there is a
decreasing volume, so the aggression of
the market participants from the volume
standpoint is getting lower and lower
and we have also a contrarian imbalance,
so we have an imbalance at the top from
the sellers. So you have the price going
up up up up up not being followed by the
volume, so you have this divergence and
the price snap back to the value, to the
efficiency of the market and you can see
that you have a rejection here. This
These signals are usually amazing
opportunities to capitalize on a
reversal trade. And from the concept of
vertical volume you can find an
exhaustion where you can see that the
market is pushing really strong,
printing another green candle, but the
volume is getting lower and lower. This
is a dry up in volume, and usually what
you see this in a pattern order flow is
that you have a sudden reversal in
price. Now, let's go through the volume
profile. Every time a limit order is
matched with a market order, we have a
transaction. Every successful
transaction, we can visualize in a way
that is distributed for each tick. And
what comes out from this point of view
is this distribution. This distribution
is the volume profile. Now, when we are
watching the volume profile, we are not
extracting from the market information
related to imbalance, not information
related to aggression, but we are
watching how market participants are
interacting from an horizontal point of
view. If we go on the right, we can see
that what the volume profile gave us,
it's a Gaussian distribution, where we
have the majority of the volume being
exchanged in this 68%
and as we move from the mean, we have a
condition that is called imbalance
market. And if we manage to go out from
the value area, usually it's where trend
start. Now, going on the concept of
value area, value area is where the
majority of the volume for the volume
profile that you are visualizing it's
exchange. And the value area is clearly
defined by value area high and value
area low. They are the points where the
68% of the volume of the distribution
took place. The point where you can see
the maximum level of transaction,
example, if we take this level here, we
can see 90 transaction happening at this
level. This one takes the name of the
POC, the so-called point of control. Why
point of control? Because from a fair
value standpoint and from a concept
related to single transaction, this one
is the level that hold the most amount
of transaction of the day if we are
talking about the daily volume profile
distribution. Now, we can see that the
highest density of executed transaction
take place here between the value area
high and the value area low. And high
execution mean strong price acceptance.
So, institutions are really happy
to transact in this area. And big
players can find a counterparty. This is
the so-called balance market condition.
Now, going on, this type of market can
be traded with multiple strategy.
Usually, strategy that fade the top and
the bottom using order flow. And this
market takes the name of range bound or
compression or consolidation. And is the
driver of the trend that is coming
after. Why you need to understand this?
Because if you want to join the trend
early in its development, you need to
understand that the when the the price
accept and the volume accept below the
value area low or the value area high,
the market participants are telling you
that we are in a situation of out of
balance. So, the accumulation or the
distribution is finished and you are
ready for the real move of the price.
Now, let's go through the concept of low
volume node. In our distribution of the
profile, we will have some point where
you can see that the price is really
low. So, on this level, the transaction
was not so efficient, okay? The delivery
was not so efficient. So, the price
probably jumped from one level to the
other with really low volume. And this
is the levels where the interaction
inefficient. You have poor fills, you
have dissatisfied market participants,
and you have low execution. So, no price
acceptance. In this case, there is an
absence of transaction. These levels are
usually the most important levels if you
want to hop in in an imbalance level
that is acting as a rejection. So, let's
say that we are balanced inside this
condition and we manage to break and we
create an imbalance here in the profile.
Usually, the market like to rebalance
the low volume node before continuing in
the direction of the trend. So, these
area are really important area from a
volume point of view because it's an
area where you don't have high density
of executed transaction. So, you don't
have a price acceptance and big players
cannot find counterparty there. So, it's
areas where you usually see a ceiling or
a bottom before resuming to the
direction of the auction. Now, price
discovery, bullish move, buy side
intent, unfilled buyers due to low
volume. Now, let's go through an example
of what I was telling you here. When you
have a low volume node and the market
goes in price discovery, you can clearly
see a lot of days the price coming back
to rebalance in this low volume node and
using this as a pivot before resuming
the direction of the auction. In this
case, you have a lot of unfilled buyers
due to the low volume node. This one
it's where you can use confluence and
order flow pattern to join the market
direction. Now, going to the auction
market theory and market structure. How
can you define where institutions, hedge
fund, banks are building value. So, big
market participants by watching what for
them is accepted as value. You can see
from here the value accepted was this.
When they go in a situation of out of
balance, they come back and they go in
price discovery on the downside and we
can mark the low volume node of this
previous distribution and this is
exactly where the price likes to come
back in the future. We are stationary
here, so we accept the value on the
downside. So, this value area high
becomes for us a strong rejection point
that paired with the low volume node
gives us all the market condition to
join the trend using order flow pattern
on this level. After this, we can see
that we have also a continuation setup.
So, when the price goes above the fair
value, that is this horizontal line, and
you can use also the merge of this
profile, the market slides back inside
the value area, and you have the setup
that brings the price from one side of
the value area to the other side. You
can also try to go in price discovery if
the price is strongly directional. After
this, we go aggressively down, and we
created another value area on the
downside, and the market start to
accumulate.
After this, we have an acceptance day,
so we have a market shift in value, and
we print multiple levels of low volume
node here. That is where the price will
likely come to rebalance because these
levels are inefficient price and volume
delivery from institutions. We accept
the value area here, and we have our
setup below the value area low joined
with low volume node, and here is where
we want to see what the market is
telling us. After this, we continue the
price delivery on the upside. We have
horizontal value being built, and when
we go back
to the value area low and down, we do
what we call the hook. So, they do a
failed auction, they try to break, they
get rejected. So, all this it's a
rejection area, and when you go back
inside, you have your continuation
trade, and so on. Now, let's see how
institutions are accepting this delivery
of volume. We have the value building on
the upside. This is what we call the P
shape. It's where the buyers are really
aggressive and you close the cash
session on the upside, so you can expect
a directional move also on the day
after. And we see another acceptance of
the value. We have the profile closing
on the upside, so we expect another
fading of the value area low to go high
or a continuation trade where we break
the value area high of the previous day.
And when the the day close, as you can
see, we continue to accept value, so we
only consider long position here. After
price having a hard time breaking the
previous value area low, you can see
that it also hook [snorts]
the value area high from the downside.
And this is what we like to call a fake
out, a failed auction, trap traders, and
you can use all the tools of order flow
to understand this in real time. And
when you have this, usually the price
slice through the value area high to go
to seek orders on the value area low.
This is one really profitable setup with
high win rate. And when you shift the
auction again, you have the shift here,
you continue to search for position
lining with the general direction of the
market when the market gives you a
premium. This is the real concept of
premium and discount. When you are going
lower with the value and the market
gives you the opportunity to join the
trend from a point that is considered
expensive in the distribution of the
volume. You have a trade that you can
join bringing heat to the value area low
or projecting it for additional price
discovery on the downside. This is the
institutional reference on how to
analyze the bias using volume, so actual
executed orders, not theory. And this
should be your starting point to build
your bias to confirm with all the order
flow tools. So now let's go in the chart
of Nasdaq. We are using a template of
deep charts that is representing the
volume profile, specifically the cash
session of the volume profile because
it's giving us the majority of the
volume of the day, and I only trade in
the New York session for US indices
because it's where the majority of the
volume get traded, and I find it from
statistical validation, the London
session to be usually for US indices not
so valuable to add to the profile. So, I
only use the cash session profile. Now,
going through single example, I want to
break down for you everything that we
saw live with the students of deep
charts from a profile framing approach.
And we will go through the last 2 months
of volume and price, so from the 20th of
November to the actual price action, so
the full 2 months from the point of view
of profile, and we will see what
information was this volume distribution
giving us in terms of bias. We'll start
from here, and we can see that we will
take this as the first reference, okay?
We have a value area here, so the
majority of the volume gets traded here,
and we will treat this as a neutral
information, okay? Now, after this, the
market tell us they accept value. We
have a strong move up. This is a
P-shape, so the buyers from daily point
of view are in control of the movement.
You can see that also the POC is higher.
It's located above the 50%. This means
that this movement is really aggressive,
and you have a clearly defined value
area low with all these rejection on the
downside. The gray area is all the
rejection, so where the price never
accepted, and this part is below the
value area low. This usually act as
support, so we want to mark it in green.
The bias is long, it's clear. We have a
clear rejection area that is the value
area low and all this absorption that
happened during the cash session of this
day, okay? The day after, the market
tried to break from the downside but
reject exactly below the value area low
in the rejection point, so the gray area
where they accumulated and absorbed the
movement the day before. Closing exactly
at the same level. So, these two profile
can be merged. You can merge them
and you can see one piece of information
because when they are overlapping on the
same level, they are just telling you
that they stayed in this balance area
for two days. After this, we have an
acceptance the day after, okay? We have
a higher POC, higher value area high and
we have a really strong movement. As you
can see, this is a double distribution
profile where you have a really thin
low. The first point that is interesting
is where the value area low is located
and then you have a big profile on the
upside that where the majority of the
volume got traded. So, you can mark all
these rejection area
from the downside and as you can see,
the price stays stationary the day
after. It stays inside. So, what you can
do, you can do from here merge and do a
double day profile on a single level and
you can have a really precise value area
low point. The day after, the market
accept higher and comes to rebalance
from the horizontal level here exactly
on this level, the 25,500
that is a psychological level and these
two profile that you can see here are on
the horizontal level. So, you can also
merge both of them.
Okay? And as you can see, the auction is
really clear. This was amazing long
trade. After this, you have three
profile on an horizontal level. Also, we
can merge them and you can identify how
much it was beautiful the rejection that
we saw from the value area low. All this
information can be paired with order
flow pattern to take precision trade.
After this, we have an acceptance and
then we start to notice something
interesting. For two day, they reject
the top here and they go lower in the
POC and the value area. So, they don't
have the value area I matching, but they
go down. So, they are starting to
distribute. So, what you can do is
noticing and putting this as a warning
because you already rejected for today
on the same level. This one could be a
market shift. Okay, so you can put
orange because you want to monitor this
properly. The market tries to go back up
again and failed. It stays still inside
the same area. So, you can decide to
merge
these two profile and you can see that
again the third day you have an amazing
rejection. So, the market is telling you
that this is a strong wall and you have
a breakout of the previous value area
low. So, this day here is telling you,
"Look, they are rejecting again." When
you exit from this whole area of
balance, you will have a trend. And this
is our confirmation day.
Look how much it was clear that they are
continuing to push the low without
accepting the high. You have a
rejection, an amazing rejection here. It
gives us a clear trend. And as you can
see from here, another test of the value
area high, amazing short here. Another
test of the value area high, amazing
short here. Another test of the value
area high, amazing short. And another
test and an amazing short. After this,
what we have? We have the market
shifting the auction. So, from a down
profile, you go in an up profile. It's
not a P-shape, so it's still balanced.
You can use this as indecision. You can
put blue instead of green, and then you
have our P-shape. Low volume on the
downside, completely absorbed, and we
have a strong P. What can we expect?
That we will have the following days of
strong trend up. And we have 1 2 3 and 4
days of strong trend up. Notice also how
much is precise the value area low
as a rejection in the cash session. Also
here, after this, you have a clear
shift. Here, you can see up and down.
And again, from here, you want to start
noticing the rejection area. Okay, so
you want to start noticing the market
joining the trend on the downside
because you are going down with the
auction. So, you have one trade, you
have down, you have all these
rejections. See, they try to break the
value area low, this two value area low,
and all this was a fake out. They got
rejected, and the market goes back down
after this shift. So, this one is an
indecision day, okay?
Where the market changed the auction
Sorry, not an indecision day. A change
of the auction here. And here, you can
see how they sustain this movement for
three following days. After this, they
tried to shift down, they failed because
this one, if you try a short, would have
been a stop loss, the first stop loss in
all these days, and they bring the
auction up. And this is a setup that we
saw in the live community together. This
long, okay? Also, this long was a setup
that we saw till the moment we shifted.
And when we shift, we start to see the
rejection on the upside, and the market
collapsed, as you can see here. [snorts]
I took this short from here. Then, it
shifted again, and then you go down,
okay? So, here, if you try to short this
value area you would have taken a stop
loss. You have a shift again, and these
two trades would pay you out. But why
the market when it reached this
sensitive level is having a stronger
rejection? Because we are on the upper
part of the distribution. So, this one
was completely predictable. And this is
the level that I gave to the community
multiple times to try the long. Also,
this one this long was anticipated. I
explained to them that they will see a
rejection from the 25,200, 180,
200 that will be really strong to go on
the upside. And this is exactly what
happened again. Now, we are going back
to the fair value of the distribution.
Now that we saw all the logic related to
the profile framing, we can go to the
execution part and the order flow
pattern. So, we saw the absorption, we
saw the exhaustion, we saw the
initiative auction. And for my first
year of order flow trading, I was using
the full profile footprint. Then, after
I became a scalper, so I have the
necessity to visualize information in a
fast and efficient way. To take fast
decision, I created this template. This
is the deep trades view and is giving
you a filter on executed orders based on
the sides. So, I only want to see big
market participants. And in this case,
for example, this was an area qualified
for the short that you can qualified as
I show you previously using the profile,
using your technical analysis
strategies, using everything. What I
watch is the interaction between my
level and the market participants, the
big market participants. In this case
here, I can see that all these effort
effort 72, 61, 60, 62. So, a total of
300 contract on this horizontal level
where also the aggressive sellers
already show their strong aggression
with result showing me that all this
effort is being absorbed. So, this is a
perfect example of absorption. This is a
confirmation for me to start building my
position on the downside and the
information for me that I can put my
position at risk-free comes immediately
3 minutes after when the market is
telling me, "Look at that. They are
adding short position." And the result
of the candle is really strong. So, I
can capitalize on this movement. Here,
you can see what we saw in the example
before. So, an absorption mid candle.
So, buyers try to enter aggressively
here, but got completely absorbed and
the candle closed sell. Now, let's go on
the up example that I took on the long
side on my account. It was a qualified
area to search for longs and the market
comes back to this area the first time.
It comes back and you can see 105
executed order on Nasdaq on this
horizontal level on the week. So, it
means that these aggressive orders got
rejected. They didn't add a result. They
got completely absorbed. The market
tried again. Fail. The market tried
again another time and the last time
that it tried, it tried with 101
contract always on the same horizontal
level. So, let's do a summary. You have
a method of qualifying important areas
that it can be volume profile, it can be
view up, it can be anything you like to
use supply and demand. And then you have
an information from the execution point
of view of the market participants. And
you can see here that also the buyers
had an hard time having a result because
they got completely absorbed. So, now we
are stuck here. You can do this ping
pong till here. And when you break this
level, you can decide to put your stop
loss to break even. So, if you decide to
enter here like this with a target here,
okay, you can decide to go from 1 to 2
to 1 to 5 and put your stop loss to
break even. What happened yesterday was
the following. So, you have another
attempt after breaking out of the
sellers of breaking complete absorption
and you have an amazing explosion on the
upside where you can trail and this for
example is my momentum model that you
saw live for 1,000 time. You can trail
your position following the aggression
of the market. So, this one print a new
one, you bring your stop loss here and
you continue, okay? And yesterday was an
amazing move on the market was really
aggressive and this is how I merge the
information that I get from volume
analysis, the information that I get
from order flow analysis and the
information that I get from result, so
from price. So, if you enjoy this video,
you will find this full map on my
Telegram and don't forget to subscribe
to the channel. I will see you in the
next video.